china's 2022 party congress is expected
to be a landmark with all eyes on the
country's leader xi jinping here's why
xi jinping is expected to disrupt the
way that power transitions in china this
year exceeding the normal two-time limit
to take a third time in power despite
the fact he exceeded the country's
normal retirement age of 68 in june
when xi jinping came into power he
stated that he wanted to achieve the
great rejuvenation of the chinese nation
which was to make it a world power again
on the global stage so far in terms of
the economy china's on track now to
surpass the us
as the world's largest in the next 10
years china has the world's largest navy
and xi jinping's flagship belt and road
foreign policy initiative has built
influence and infrastructure all around
the world however under xi china has
become more closed the internet has
become far more regulated and he's
overseen a campaign of oppression in
xinjiang which the us has called
genocide a crackdown on freedoms in hong
kong and put pressure on taiwan all of
that has fractured relations with the
west and more recently his covert zero
policy after being so successful at
containing deaths in the early pandemic
is giving china's economy a real
bruising
some 2 000 delegates from all across
china will descend on beijing these
include top military officials
provincial party leaders farming
representatives and people from china's
minority groups they'll huddle behind
closed doors for five days and decide
everything from policy priorities to
sort of who's leading the country
although actually much of that has been
decided beforehand but only at the end
of the congress afterwards xi jinping
will walk out in a sort of press
conference with his top cabinet behind
him in order of rank and only then will
people really understand who it is that
xi jinping and the party have selected
to be the country's most powerful men
[Music]
xi jinping has overseen an
anti-corruption campaign in the past 10
years which has pretty much eliminated
all of his rivals however there are
still a few rising stars and it will be
interesting to see what position they
land in these include chen minou and
huchenhua who are long time shi
associates
people will also be very closely
watching where li tiang ends up this is
the shanghai party secretary he is a
close sheet ally he was tipped to enter
the politburo standing committee but
after overseeing a pretty disastrous
kobe campaign in shanghai there are
rumors that he might no longer get a
promotion